bazongas
huge turn off nasty [__]
what's up I'm Kim Petras and today I'm
going to be reading thirst tweets
slightly terrified but also excited
[Music]
Kim your music has made me happy every
day since I discovered it years ago
you're a beautiful gorgeous stunning
goddess I hope you truly truly know that
as deeply as we do oh thank you that's
not a thirst tweet but that's a very
sweet tweet thank you so much little
angel
cute I know one thing Kim Petras and
Nikki's face card about to eat you
[__] up when the visuals drop came so
pretty to me
thanks girl you I appreciate it but
Queen Nikki
gorgeous
so stunning Queen icon Queen Empress
goddess Supreme Legend mother alejina
Diva young successful influential
capable talented sincere blooming
calling for kisses angelically beautiful
flammable with tenderly passionate eyes
Kim Petrus mommy please feed us
thank you so much I'm trying to feed you
always and I feel like I have been doing
a better job at it so I don't know what
you're getting at with that but
thank you girl Kim Petras is so sexy
thank you you too so hot I want to eat
Kim Petras coconuts
I mean makes sense who wouldn't Kim
Petrus helped me realize I'm a [__]
thank you competitors you know that's
one of like my proudest achievements in
life when people say things like this
just makes me so happy and proud of all
of you look how far we've come it's
really been a journey to get here but
now we're realizing these things
go [__] I want to eat a baguette though
Kim Petrus boobs
you said what you said there
competitors as nice bizangas
thanks that's I I write songs about them
they're my friends
always with me I'm never alone that's
my girls for real so yeah bazangas
bazangas I won Kim Petrus to fight me to
demons demons underrated Bob and
honestly huge turn on that you're a fan
of traffic light so I say yes let's do
it
every time I watch the Kim Petras
coconuts dance video I do get a little
more lesbian hell yeah that makes me
really happy for you
and you should know that all these
thirst tweets are like really nice I'm
just like wow thank you for being horny
Kim Petrus has nice to pass it on that's
what I keep saying like not enough
people are talking about that I have
boobs and I think a lot more people need
to know about this I'm really grateful
for you going on Twitter and spreading
awareness it really helps me out and it
really helps the fans out it's just good
all around for everyone
to be honest if competious my boyfriend
I'd thank her
oh
I don't know if that's a compliment but
cool my whole hand emoji Do Me by Kim
Petras that song was specifically
designed for that so you saying that
just makes me feel like I'm really good
at songwriting you know and it was
literally made for that so I'm happy it
found its place in the world so
effortlessly yeah you're welcome
happy Pride I want Kim Petras to sit on
my face everyone at Pride says this
heard it a million times before and I'm
kidding cool hell yeah you not you're
nasty I like it
it's really horny hours please eat my
ass competitors
sometimes it is like that
doing poppers at the Kim Petras concert
so my whole goes
okay I need to do that one more time
just for the living doing poppers at the
Kim Petras concert so my whole goes
I mean it's what needed to be said and
what needed to be done
for a reason and you are one of the few
people who knows the reason so I respect
you [__] Kim Petrus has reawakened my
inner [__] and rekindled my desire for
you're going to hell
[Laughter]
always be
Kim patches speaking German my [__]
doth quiver
and the tongue breaker [__] doth
I like Darth though I might start saying
dog for fun so thank you for the advice
like honestly I've lost my German accent
so much like I kind of want it back
because like whenever you hear another
person have an accent I'm like that's
hot it just left my body at some point
and I don't know why because mine like
people think I'm from like New Zealand I
need to work on that thank you for
reminding me keeping me on my toes you
inspired me today
yeah go to Queen get up they don't
really say go off but gear would be the
German version just for all of you who
don't know German I'm a shut up now shut
up okay who's
do I need to use as eye cream for a free
campetress ticket that's just giving
like ritual stuff it's giving like
Beauty and like
medieval times I'm kind of into it is
there any like evidence of anything like
that because people do talk about that
stuff behind closed doors but never in
public so you're really brave for
bringing that subject up I know that's a
really tough subject for a lot of people
skincare so really glad you brought it
up because this conversation needs to be
had one mile
want my whole plowed raw welcome
pictures is playing when you're about to
tell me so I can say I'm so glad I made
it into your guys's life like that
that's really like personal and close
and it just really makes me feel like I
did the right thing you know I taught
you guys the right values and you just
know what it's about you're a real
button head and some things just need to
be done I hear you
just always know that I hear you pointy
tweets are the best Tweets honestly
everyone should just only tweet all the
time thank you so much for watching my
there's tweets thank you for being real
that was really fun I see you I love you
and make sure you stream my new single
alone with Nicki Minaj song of the
summer
too much
[Music]